this is a production of Cornell
University and thank you for the
invitation to be here today and for
letting me choose my own topic to speak
about because those of you who know me
probably know that for much of the past
decade I've really worked mainly on
irrigation control my students like to
say that I'm a control freak I've been
controlling irrigation I don't want to
stop there I now want to control light
and I want to control light in a smarter
way and what we have done in the past
and much of my work was inspired by a
book that was published in 2011 I think
it's an interesting book and is full of
vague claims to our understanding of
plant science but it inspired a lot of
people and quite frankly the book was
written by Dixon de-spawn yay we may not
agree with the claims that he makes but
I think we should thank him for putting
controlled environment agriculture on
the forefront of night of a national
discussion about how we are going to
grow food in the future and so I think
because he is incredible at PR there are
lots of people who are really interested
in vertical forms in producing food and
places where we may or may not be able
to grow food efficiently but it has
generated a lot of research
opportunities if nothing else I think
the people who are probably most
fascinated with vertical farms were
architects because as soon as this book
came out Orkut that started architects
started making beautiful designs for
what vertical farms should look like and
it is actually a lot of fun to just
Google images for vertical farms because
they are absolutely beautiful they
probably don't work but I would love to
see and this building right here
wouldn't that be cool to be able to
visit that let's hope someone has gonna
invest in that thing and make it happen
German engineer engineers not architects
they took a slightly more pragmatic
approach to what it would take to
actually run a vertical farm so they
came up with this design and it's not
nearly as pretty but I did all of the
engineering to try to figure out what
actually take to build a large vertical
farm and produce food year-round in a
facility like that so this vertical farm
has a footprint of forty four by forty
four million meters it is 37 floor tall
and they probably over engineered the
building since these are aerospace
engineers and they do like to over
engineer things but I look then at how
much does it cost to build this and this
building would be a little bit over 300
million dollars so we need a substantial
investment to be able to make that
happen
but what I was more interested in is
that the analysis that they did on what
it takes to actually run that facility
on a year-to-year basis so it turns out
that the power consumption for this
vertical farm would be four hundred
thousand kilowatts kilowatt hours per
day and it would cost about 32 to 35
million dollars these values here are in
euros a year to pay for the power for
this electricity now this number
probably doesn't mean a whole lot to you
but 400,000 kilowatt hours a day it's
pretty much when you compare that to a
household a typical household is about
30 kilowatt hours per day and it turns
out that this number right here is
probably pretty close to the power
consumption of Ithaca the city decides
so that's what it takes to run this one
vertical farm so there is a tremendous
amount of power that you need to do this
and much of the cost of running these
things sixty percent is in power
consumption their calculations show that
half of this 30% of total operating cost
was to run the LEDs much of the rest of
the power use would be for air
conditioning and part of that air
conditioning is new is needed to remove
the heat that you actually get from the
LEDs so in reality the cost of running
lights is probably about 40 to 50
percent of the total cost to run a
facility like this and it's a lot of
money my research isn't just limited to
vertical farms this is an example of a
small
vertical form that is actually just
outside of Atlanta that close to the
airport they located next to the airport
because they get naturally 800 parts per
million co2 they're apparently just from
the airplane sneaking off it's pretty
amazing how much co2 that generates so
they typically use very little co2
enrichment they don't have to but so you
can see here that are working with
fluorescent lights they grow these
plants under amazingly low light levels
but still for them the light is a big
cost for them in greenhouses worst-case
scenario you may be spending up to about
$500 a day on the power to run
supplemental lighting in the greenhouses
this too when you add that up over the
course of a year that can be a
substantial amount of money just last
week I was in a hundred acre greenhouse
where they use supplemental lighting I
don't know what the power bill is but
they spent millions of dollars a year on
electricity for their lighting so it can
be expensive so people think that LEDs
are the solution to everything and the
question is are LEDs the solution to
solve these lighting issues and
controlled environment agriculture first
of all when people tell you that LEDs
don't generate heat just laughs just
start laughing right away you hear that
claim a lot just not possible
so LEDs good LEDs right now I think of
30 maybe 40 percent efficient that means
that's the energy that gets converted
into light all of that other energy is
gonna have to go somewhere that is basic
physics so all that other energy is heat
that gets generated the difference
between LEDs and most other light so
that we normally use is that the LED
light itself you can get really close to
it it doesn't generate a lot of heat
it's the electronics on the back side of
the LED where the heat is generated and
that heat you actually have to remove if
you don't remove that and LED will burn
up and in
probably milliseconds if not seconds so
LEDs have been around for a while the
two green lights show different kinds of
LEDs right here but they have really
become more prevalent in the last five
to ten years and one reason that I have
become so much more common than they
used to be sorry is that the efficiency
of LEDs has rapidly increased so it is a
rapidly evolving technology and right
now people may argue about whether they
are more efficient or equally efficient
as the best high pressure sodium lights
that are out on the market there may not
be much of a difference in efficiency at
this point but LED technology since it
is still relatively new is likely to
become substantially more efficient than
any other light source we have right now
so that makes it a good choice
potentially for supplemental lighting or
for salsas lighting where you grow
plants in a completely enclosed
environment so another advantage in
addition to the efficiency is that LEDs
if you use them correctly they can last
a very long time and that using them
correctly it's mainly depending on
making sure they don't get more power
than they shoot because that will
quickly wear them out and make sure that
they cool that they are cool that
appropriately I mentioned previously
that the light itself does not get hot
so that means that you can have these
like these lights very close to the
canopy or you can even put them inside
of the canopy so this is the picture of
Philips light bars where I put them
inside of a tomato crop and it doesn't
burn the leaves so that's it that is a
big difference compared to the more
traditional high-intensity discharge
lights that we've always used in in
greenhouses another advantage of this is
that this actually allows you to get
light into the bottom part of the canopy
when you use traditional high-intensity
discharge lights you would have your
life somewhere above the canopy
obviously of the picture here that light
is coming down but is going to be
absorbed almost entirely by the leaves
in the top of the canopy so this is a
way to gather more
light distribution and that should help
overall canopy photosynthesis there is a
drawback to LEDs and they are still very
expensive they are getting cheaper they
are continuously getting cheaper but
right now the question of whether or not
it is actually cost effective to replace
high-intensity discharge lights with
LEDs there's a pretty tough question to
answer do you get enough benefits from
them to make it worthwhile to make that
replacements but we are still in many
cases when I look at LED research we are
using LEDs as if they are just a
replacement for traditional lights and
LEDs have much more capability than a
high-pressure sodium or metal halide
light you can get them in pretty much
any spectrum that you want but what I am
most interested in is controlling the
light levels that we get from the LED
lights and matching that light level to
the physiological ability of the plants
to actually use that light so it turns
out that controlling LEDs is actually
very easy and very cheap it's not often
that you have that combination the
investment is practically nothing if you
want to do this
so with LEDs one thing that we can do is
we can very easily control the frequency
at which they turn on and off and you
probably don't realize that but the
spend of demo that you may have in this
room or that you may have at home and
light them actually does the same thing
it turns off the current to your light
bulb on and off at a high frequency we
can tell that because it goes so fast
that our eyes cannot detect it but so
with LEDs we can turn these lights on
and off but in addition to that what we
can do then is we can control the duty
cycle of the LEDs so what that means is
with them one on off cycle so this is
off on and off again how long are these
LEDs actually on so in this example here
we have a 50% duty cycle and that
basically gives us effectively half
of the light output that you get from
when the LEDs are on full-time so this
would be a medium light level if we go
to a 10 percent duty cycle the LEDs are
only on a small amount of the time and
you get a much lower light level and
then likewise if you increase the duty
cycle you get higher light levels so we
just think that duty cycle is really
easy I didn't realize that this until I
as an engineer if he could build a board
for me and he said well yes I could but
I'll just have an undergrad put it
together for you apparently it is that
complicate it so sometimes it is good to
talk to engineers it's Lou here so what
I am focused on is what I want to do is
to optimize the light to its efficiency
so I'm going to go through the
physiology of what actually happens to
light when you are providing light to
the crop and then that will get us to
how we are using that plant physiology 9
physiological background to actually
control the lights so ultimately what
really needs to happen in the light
reactions of photosynthesis is that we
have to make NADPH and ATP plants don't
use light very efficiently necessarily
sometimes they do sometimes they don't
it largely depends on how much light you
give them the more light you give a
plant the less efficiently the plant is
actually using that light but the way
this works in the chloroplast is LED
light gets absorbed by chlorophyll
molecules and what hopefully will happen
is that excitation energy from that
photon is transferred from one
chlorophyll to an order and ultimately
to the reaction center of either
photosystem one or photosystem two and
there that energy from that photon is
used to move an electron from one
reformer donor to an acceptor and then
reason a whole electron transport chain
that follows this so this process is
referred to as photochemistry this is
what we want to happen with the light
that is absorbed by Lise
and when that happens so this gives you
a better idea of the overall electron
transport chain we have a photon that
comes in this case from the Sun it
reaches the reaction center of
photosystem 2 and then in the electron
goes from water it is transported
initially to this point and this is the
rate limiting step I'll come back to
that later this turns out to be
important for some of the work that we
do and if it gets past this bottleneck
then that electron moves ultimately to
NADPH and now we have reductant that
gets produced that can be used in the
calvin cycle to ultimately make
carbohydrates at the same time what is
happening in this process is that
hydrogen actually moves from the stroma
into the lumen and hydrogen is produced
from the splitting of water right here
so we get a pH gradient across this
membrane and that that pH gradient is
used right here to make ATP so now we
have NADPH and ATP and that is
ultimately the energy that is going to
drive the Calvin cycle unfortunately not
all of the light that is absorbed by a
leaf is actually used for photochemistry
some of the light is actually going to
be converted into heat and plants have
the ability to control how much of that
light gets converted into heat and that
control is actually based on that pH
gradient that develops across the file
according inside of the chloroplast so
we're moving hydrogen's into the lumen
if a plant can use all of this hydrogen
to make ATP then we don't get much of a
drop in pH right here but if the
hydrogen transport across this membrane
is faster than the rate at which that
hydrogen can be used to make ATP then we
get a drop in pH right here if that
happens that triggers an enzymatic
activation with an enzyme called via
violas lengthen deep oxidase I get
activated by low pH inside of the lumen
viola xanthine deep oxidase converts
viola xanthine which is a xanthophyll
pigment that
present in the claw in the thylakoid
membrane it converted to anther Atlantan
and subsequently to zeaxanthin and that
conversion is reversible when the pH
increases again the reason that this
conversion is important is that viola
xanthine is a pigment that helps
chloroplasts absorb light and transfer
that line to the reaction centers when
viola xanthine gets converted into
amphoras lanthanum zeaxanthin these two
pigments actually act very differently
those two pigments cause the absorb
light energy to be converted into heat
they have an impact on the surrounding
chlorophyll molecules and prevent
chlorophyll molecules from transferring
that energy from one chlorophyll
molecule to another and instead that
energy now is lost as heat that may seem
like a bad thing but this is a way that
plants can protect themselves from
excess light and then there is a third
potential fate for absorb light energy
and that is chlorophyll fluorescence
doesn't seem to be something that is
actually actively controlled by plants
but it happens so you cannot see it but
every plant that is exposed to light s
fluorescing it is giving off red light
with a wavelength of around 619
animators you actually can see it if you
get a green laser pointer and you point
that at a leaf you can see a radish glow
where you hit that leaf that is actually
red photons coming from that leaf after
you give it only green light so close
your fluorescence it turns out is
actually really easy to measure there
are very good techniques out there you
can buy the equipment not necessarily
cheap but it's not difficult to do so
this is an example here of a crow Phil
for Ramadan when we measure chlorophyll
fluorescence basically what we are
measuring is how much light is emitted
from that leaf at a wavelength of around
695 nanometers and so there is light
that is emitted that photon is created
inside of the leaf it does not reflect
it
that's a very different thing and so to
measure that we typically measure the
fluorescence coming from the leaf under
ambient light conditions and then in
this picture right here you can see a
very bright spot right here where you
also measure the chlorophyll
fluorescence when you give the leaf an
amount of light that completely
saturates all of the photosystems in
that little part of the leaf and from
those measurements we can actually
calculate all kinds of things and this
is where we can get a lot of in depth
physiological information incredibly
easily I'm still always a bit
dumbfounded when I think about the
biophysical processes that we can
measure so easily by shining a light
onto the leaf so if you take these
measurements on a leaf that has been in
the dark for a while then you can
measure something called the maximum
quantum yield the photosystem 2 and that
indicates whether that leaf is healthy
or not where the photosystem 2 in that
leaf has been damaged by heat excess
light salinity whatever it doesn't
matter but you can detect whether or not
was damage to photosystem 2 so for a
healthy leaf you're typically looking
for a maximum quantum yield of 0.8 -
what that value of 0.8 - means is that
under those conditions that leaf uses 82
percent of the light that it absorbs for
photochemistry for electron transport
and that's the process that we need to
get transpiration at sorry to get
photosynthesis we can take these same
measurements on a leaf that is exposed
to light and now we can measure the
intrinsic quantum yield in light and
that is actually more interesting
because that actually tells us under
let's say greenhouse conditions if you
do this in a greenhouse you can measure
how efficiently that plant is using the
light that it is getting what fraction
of light it is absorbed by the leaf is
actually used for photochemistry
so that in principle is something that
we would like to be as high as possible
we won't play
to use light as efficiently as possible
if we know the quantum yield of
photosystem two the entrance the quantum
yield we can actually so that's going to
be abbreviated as Phi PS to the four
efficiency of photosystem two we can
calculate the electron transport rate of
photosystem two because we know the
efficiency with which light is used we
can very easily measure the amount of
life of light that is getting to the
leaf and we typically make the
assumption that 84% of the light that
reaches the leaf is going to be absorbed
by that leaf that's a value that is
roughly accurate for a wide range of
different species and then we multiply
that by 0.5 and that is to account for
the fact that we have two photosystems
and the assumption is that half of the
light is going to photosystem two half
of the light is going to photosystem one
and then based on that we can calculate
the electron transport rate and in that
leaf and so we got all of that basically
from shining a light onto that leaf and
measuring how much fluorescence is
emitted from that leaf the last
parameter that I want to talk about that
we can calculate as non photochemical
quenching non photochemical quenching is
an indicator of the activity of the
central cycle how much of the absorb
light energy is actually converted into
heat some non photochemical quenching in
principle we would like to be low
because if you get a lot of thermal
dissipation of light energy that means
that the efficiency of photosystem two
is going down less light is actually
being used for photochemistry
and this is calculated from the
fluorescence that you measure under the
saturated light poles so our goal we
started on there's about a year and a
half ago was to develop a biofeedback
system to measure chlorophyll
fluorescence then calculate the electron
transport rate and then adjust the duty
cycle of the LEDs to maintain whatever
electron transport rate we program into
the system so before we started doing
that we needed to understand just what
these plants were doing under LED light
so we had an LED light right here with a
power supply a plan below it a
fluorometer for chlorophyll fluorescence
connected to a data logger the data
logger is controlling the fluorometer it
tells the fluorometer when to take a
measurement and it gets the data from
the fluorometer them and a light sensor
so that we can calculate the electron
transport rate so we just collected data
on the sperry state conditions where we
turn to LEDs on this is a picture of
what it looks like inside of the growth
chamber this is a very early picture you
can actually see the flickering nature
of the LEDs in that picture that was
captured by the camera right here these
stripes that you see there's actually
the result of how the camera shutter is
detecting the light and this is our Rafa
ugly control system that runs the whole
system it's not pretty but it works most
of the time so when we expose these
plants this was with lettuce for now in
this case this was 14 hours I believe to
400 micro moles of photosynthetic photon
flux what we see over the course of that
period is that the electron transport
rate gradually decreases and the
electron transport rate decreases
because the efficiency of photosystem 2
decreases over time and the efficiency
of photosystem 2 decreases because non
photochemical quenching is upregulated
as these plants are exposed to these
relatively high light levels for lettuce
for a prolonged period one thing that I
do want to point out though is that the
scales here when we look at the
magnitude of the change it's actually
fairly small so we have about a 5%
change decrease in electron transport
rate the same for the efficiency of
photosystem 2 decreases by about 5% and
P Q those values are just really
difficult to interpret
itself doesn't mean a whole lot other
than at a higher value indicates that
more of the absorbed life is being
converted into heat
no these plans were under 16 hours of
light 8 hours of dark so when we look at
the relationship between non photo cam
non photochemical quenching and the
efficiency of photosystem 2 you see that
there is a pretty nice relationship
between the two so that it's very
consistent with the idea that the
upregulation of the xanthophyll cycle is
a mechanism that decreases the
efficiency of photosystem 2 but at the
same time helps to protect the plants
against damage from excess light so we
have to be had this system where we just
had LEDs and we could measure the flames
below them so we had to adapt this
system to actually give us control
active control over LEDs so the engineer
that I mentioned previously he billed as
a duty cycle of frequency control board
we can control that from the data logger
by sending a voltage signal using an
analog output module to the frequency
control board and now the data logger
can tell the LED lives basically what
duty cycle should you maintain what
should the frequency be and I'm not
going to talk about frequency that has
turned out to be a really boring aspect
of everything that we've done they've
had no impact whatsoever but the duty
cycle basically when we adjust adjust
the duty cycle we're adjusting the light
level that we give to the plants so the
question was can we maintain a steady
electron transport rate well so we tried
we actually use a different lattice plan
this time but we try to maintain a
stable electron transport rate of 70
micromoles per square meter per second
so that the 70 micro moles of electrons
that move through one square meter of
leaf in one second and all of them the
first few minutes we were actually able
to control that electron transport rate
I thought very nicely we were very happy
to see this
as I'll point out in a second it was
amazingly easy to control the electron
transport rate of 70 micro moles though
but we tried different levels so this is
a similar graph with a higher electron
transport rates it's a little bit more
noisy but overall we still have very
nice control over the electron transport
rate so we have a way now that we can
actually control the rate of the light
reactions of photosynthesis by simply
adjusting the duty cycles of the LEDs
one of the nice thing about fluorescence
measurements is that you get a lot of
physiological information so this showed
how the efficiency of photosystem 2
changed with an electron transport rate
set at 70 and the efficiency of
photosystem 2 is always the same
there was no down regulation so what
that basically means is to maintain an
electron transport rate of 70 micro
moles per square meter per second if the
efficiency of the leaf doesn't change
you're always maintaining the same light
level and you're right there
so you just turn the lights on walk away
and you're actually fine there wasn't
any active control needed one thing that
was good to see is that in the dark
before and after the trial
we got quantum yields of over 0.8 and
that indicates that these leaves were
actually healthy and not damaged during
this process I'll get back to that later
but it turns out we can actually cause
severe damage to the leaves just by
taking these measurements so when I add
the quantum yield of photosystem 2 for
the higher electron transport rates to
this first of all you see that the
efficiency is lower when you have higher
electron transport rates when you give
plants more light again they use that
light less efficiently so we see a
decrease in the quantum yield of about
0.6 3 to maybe point 5 8 or so so the
plants at this higher light level did
become less and less efficient over time
so we also looked at non photochemical
quenching what we see at the lower
electron transport rate is that non
photochemical quenching is very boring
and always the same when we go to higher
like from transport race we have more
known for the chemical quenching than at
lower electron transport rates because
we have more light and at the same time
we see that non photochemical quenching
is upregulated over the course of this
day so the plant is inducing that van to
fill cycle activity to help protect
itself from light damage and then
ultimately when we look at the light
levels that we'll need to maintain these
electron transport rates so this is the
light that we need it over this period
to maintain an electron transport rate
of 70 so basically the biofeedback
system that we developed didn't have to
make any adjustments whatsoever
in light level of 240 micro moles per
square meter per second was just what
these plants needed at the higher target
electron transport rate of 100 though we
see led to by a feedback system needed
to up regulate the duty cycle and the
light level to maintain a stable rate of
electron transport so it showed us that
the system works that was exciting
enough to see in the early days of this
work the whole Lab group would come set
around the lattice plan in the lab and
we would just see what would happen next
to the light we had hooked up to it and
it was actually really fascinating to
watch that plant basically adjusting the
light to whatever level it needed we
were also interested in seeing what
rates can we actually achieve with this
kind of a biofeedback system we worked
with different species I am only going
to talk about lattice because the other
species they don't respond all that
differently so it's not that interesting
and we were interested in looking at
what is the physiology that underlies
the process is that that we see so our
goal was to maintain the electron
transport rate of lettuce at different
levels over the course of a day so we
would increase the target electron
transport rate according to this dotted
line that you see right here going from
initially zero up to 70 micro moles per
square meter per second and then back
down again because we had each target
electron transport rate for only one
hour
we were collecting chlorophyll
fluorescence data more often in the
study to give the system enough time to
measure electron transport rate at a
particular level and to make the needed
adjustments in the duty cycle of the
LEDs to be able to maintain that
electron transport rate so here we were
measuring every two minutes and so this
is the level of control that we got that
actually I thought looked pretty good
where we can maintain these definite
electron transport rates pretty well so
we reached a limit right here this plant
simply couldn't do any more than this
and then going back down again we
regained control of the electron
transport rate that's the one thing that
you may notice here hopefully you didn't
there's as four things they don't work
the maximum electron transport rate that
we got was only about 60 micro moles per
square meter per second I just showed
you in the previous studies that we have
no trouble maintaining electron
transport rates of up to 100 micro moles
per square meter per second so when we
looked at the light levels that we'll
need it to achieve these electron
transport rates we see a stepwise
pattern here we were maxing out the
light that we could get from the LEDs
and then it goes back down again but one
thing that is interesting in this is
that we needed a lot more light to
maintain a specific electron transport
rate during the first half of the trial
then during the second half of the trial
so both of these lines indicate the
light level needed to maintain an
electron transport rate right here of 10
micro moles per square meter per second
but at the end of the day we needed
almost twice as much light as we did
during the beginning of the day and so
our initial thought was well this is a
regulation of non photochemical
quenching in these plants we see the
same difference here at an electron
transport rate of 50 this is the
difference in light level that we need
it at this point in time for us at this
point in time so these plants were
becoming less and less efficient over
the course of this 14 hour period when
we look
at the efficiency of photosystem two or
a quantum yield we see that during the
initial part of that trial the quantum
yield dropped which is what we would
expect as you increase light levels the
efficiency of photosystem two increases
but the efficiency did not really go up
a whole lot during the second half of
the trial until we actually turned off
the lights so the efficiency of
photosystem two here did not recover and
when I took a closer look at these data
another thing that I noticed was that
when we look at the quantum yield this
initial data right here that's in the
dark first of all these values are
pretty low we started about 0.72
and then the efficiency of photosystem 2
was decreasing during that initial hour
in the dark so that was actually
indicating that our measurements as
measurement chlorophyll fluorescence was
changing the efficiency of photosystem 2
and then at the end of the trial when we
measured the yield again here in the
dark
we only got quantum yields of around 0.6
0.6 at the end of the day and that's all
this we are really damaging these leaves
so this indicates a problem and we have
now narrowed that problem down to the
fact that we were simply measuring
chlorophyll fluorescence too often and
it's at saturating light poles that has
an intensity of around 6,000 micromoles
per square meter per second that's a lot
of light that is three times of the
maximum amount of light that you may get
during the middle of summer and exposing
that leaf to that very high light level
every two minutes was actually causing
damage to that leaf so when we look at
the changes in non photochemical
quenching we see that non photochemical
quenching gets regulated as the light
levels increase and non photochemical
quenching is actually nicely down
regulated again as we decrease light
levels when we try to maintain
progressively lower electron transport
rates so non for the chemical quenching
could not explain the difference that we
saw in yield early in this trial versus
late in this trial
this is another way to look at this so
the solar symbols right here they
indicate the relationship between non
photochemical quenching and the measured
quantum yield and we see this is in the
dark the yield decreases as known for
the chemical quenching increases but
then during the second half of the trial
as the light levels decrease non
photochemical quenching decreases again
but the yield doesn't increase the way
you would expect so after I realized
that this was happening we had a lab
meeting to talk about this it took us a
while to figure out what was going on
why do we not see that yield recovering
in the afternoon
even though not photochemical quenching
gets down regulated and then we took a
look at the raw data from the
fluorescence measurements and so this is
the fluorescence that is measured under
the saturating light this is an
indicator of non photochemical quenching
the lower this value the more known for
the chemical quenching and we see that
spice pattern that is associated with
changes in the electron transport rate
changes in light level and a recovery
again later in the day the next line
this is the fluorescence signal that we
measured on these leaves under ambient
light conditions without saturating
light pearls and what we saw early in
the day is that that fluorescence
increase and that is normal as light
levels increase but during the second
half of the day that prices didn't
decrease back down again that
fluorescence actually kept increasing
and this indicates damage that we had
caused to photosystem 2 by trying to
measure chlorophyll fluorescence more
frequently than these plants could
handle so the way that that damage
happens is through a process that is
called photo inhibition so under normal
conditions you have an active
photosystem 2 that is capable of taking
an electron from water and moving it on
through the electron transport chain if
you apply too much light to plants for
the system to
can actually become inactivated and it
is actually a really ingenious mechanism
through which these words so if you have
too much light basically what happens is
that too many electrons get taken from a
water molecule these electrons normally
would be moving through this electron
transport chain but they can't in this
case because there is so much light that
was not enough capacity that electron is
going to react with something and in
this case what happens is that in
photosystem two that excess energy is
actually specifically directed towards a
protein that is called 2d1 protein that
protein gets damaged and the plant can
then take that protein out of the
reaction center of photosystem two and
put a new one end but this takes a few
hours so it is a slow repair process but
think about how ingenious is this when
you think about this in the context of
your car let's say you're driving your
car something goes wrong in the engine
if you had a smart engine that was a
smart as a plant that engine would
direct whatever is going wrong in that
engine to your first spark plug make
that blow up and all you need to do to
repair it as we place that spark plug no
matter what that is basically what
plants have done they direct all of that
energy well maybe not all but they
directed energy to the d1 protein and
then the plan essentially knows what it
needs to repair is the d1 protein that
needs to be repaired and obviously
plants have a very efficient mechanism
to repair that protein because they know
that that is what is going to be damaged
so we get this photo inhibition plants
can reactivate photosystem 2 but this
can be a matter of hours so what we saw
in our trials we think we're pretty
confident about this it's photo
inhibition that was induced by those
light forces so what we do know from
these studies is that we can control
electron transport rate over a wide
range of different levels we can do it
in many species I haven't shown that
here because it's not really interesting
to look at the same graphs for different
species when we do get high electron
transport rates that
is associated with a low yield and high
Nam photochemical quenching so we also
found that too frequent but of
measurements can result in photo in
ambition and what we do now is we
measure that fluorescence and the
saturating light only once every 15
minutes and that seems to be fine we're
not seeing any damage from that but the
good thing is that we can actually see
photo inhibition happening if we take a
close enough look at the data because
that photo inhibition should be evident
from an upward trend in the basal
fluorescence that you're measuring so
this was part of what we've been working
on we have by a feedback system and now
that we understand the damage that we
get from the measurements I think we'll
be able to run this without causing
damage from the measurements but we're
working on other things as well and one
thing that LEDs have done is they have
actually generated a lot of interest in
Makris action spectrum of photosynthesis
so this curve right here shows how
efficiently plants use different
wavelengths of photons for
photosynthesis and it's normalized to a
peak of one right here so with LEDs we
can actually get very specific
wavelengths and there's a lot of
interest right now in trying to recreate
the action spectrum and see if this
holds up and the LEDs and see if it
holds up under different light
intensities so because there's a lot of
interest in this I'm not doing it a lot
of people are and what I'm gonna do is
try to convince you that this doesn't
work because that's much more fun I like
to be contrarian but so because the
efficiency is relatively high in the
blue and red part of the spectrum and we
have good LEDs in those wavelengths
efficient LEDs the typical grow light
now has a mixture of red and blue LEDs
we are actually using some of these
exact same lights this is just another
grow light but that has become the
standard mixing red and blue in some
cases white LEDs but what Keith McCree
and has groundbreaking drug in the sea
these didn't seem to think about was
even more groundbreaking work that was
done in the fifties by Amazon so Amazon
is largely credited for doing the
initial research that showed that were
actually two different photo systems
that work together an electron transport
rate and what Amazon did was he looked
at photosynthetic rates if we only give
plants light with wavelengths greater
than 680 nanometers and what he found
was that you get very low photosynthetic
rates and with what we know now that is
actually to be expected because
photosystem 2 can only use light with
wavelength of 680 or below well
photosystem one can use light up to 700
nanometers so with this kind of light
you're really only stimulating
photosystem 1 not for the system to so
what Emerson also found and I think we
have failed to really recognize the
importance of this is that if you give
plants light with wavelengths only below
680 nanometers and that's this right
here we also get low photosynthetic
rates but that light can still excite
for the system to and photosystem 1 both
but we still get only very low
photosynthetic rates and when we combine
these two lights then you get this right
here you get much much higher
photosynthetic rates much higher than
using eat well then the combination of
these two lights when used individually
so there is a synergistic effect of
light below and light above 680
nanometers and the idea behind that is
that I showed this slide before the rate
limiting step and the electron transport
train is right here where this electron
needs to be a transfer to a plastic he
known right here and that will allow
that electron to move further down the
electron transport chain so we often say
that for the system to is the rate
limiting spec for the light reactions
and that is because photosystem 2 right
here is not capable of donating this
electron to the plastic enon pool right
here
if most of that plastic in own pool has
already been reduced there's only so
much blessed to be known but based on
what Amazon found basically what we can
do is if we excite for the system one
more what we can do is reoxidized all
these downstream intermediates and the
electron transport chain and if we can
oxidize the plastically nodes right here
then they can accept another electron
and for the system to now is capable of
transferring that electron more
efficiently and electron transport can
occur at a higher rate theoretically so
there goes the electron all the way to
NADPH so I told a graduate student of
mine about 10 days ago if she could get
me convincing data on this by last
Wednesday so she had about four days to
do this I'll let you go to the light
symposium at Michigan State and she got
pretty motivated so she grabbed a red
and blue LED board it has this spectrum
right here and we have some four red
LEDs sitting in the lab and she added
incrementally more for red light to it
and then she measured photosynthetic
rates and she measured the quantum yield
of photosystem two and so this is a far
red LED right here it asked practically
no photosynthetically active radiation
there was virtually no light below 700
nanometers so when she did that the
y-axis here is really confusing because
this data is so new that we haven't
figured out yet how we actually want to
express this but this indicates the
current that we were giving to the
forward LEDs it's basically the
intensity of the far red light so it
goes from zero with the far red off to
more and more far red light and then the
far red light turned off again and what
we see is indeed an increase in
photosynthesis that is disproportional
to the amount of light that we were
adding so we have now made the great
discovery that signs don't in the
50s was actually right but I think we
have forgotten about the science from
the 50s and that's really the point I'm
trying to make it's really worthwhile to
look at some key papers from a very long
time ago because there is a lot of good
information out there and what we were
also able to do but Emerson never could
do because he doesn't have the equipment
we looked at the quantum yield of
photosystem 2 and it actually follows a
very very similar pattern but the
increase that we see in the quantum
yield the photosystem 2 is actually not
as big as the increase that we see in
photosynthesis so this by itself doesn't
explain the entire effect that we see on
the actual photosynthetic measurements
we haven't had any time to look at this
and more depth of the thing about this a
whole lot I got these gravel on Saturday
I think so but I think it's just
interesting to go back to that old
literature and so there was a lot of
interest in Makris action spectrum of
photosynthesis and the reason that I say
maybe it's not all that important is
that that action spectrum that McCree
developed and it was great work but it
assumes that all of these wave lines are
acting independently and they don't we
know from Amazon that for red light has
a synergistic effect and that becomes
really difficult to capture in any light
in an action spectrum that might mean
that you need to develop an action
spectrum with different amounts of for
red light added to it or something like
that and as far as like the only kind of
light that has this kind of an effect
who knows we can't possibly test all
different possibilities all different
wavelengths of light because that would
be hundreds if not thousands of
different wavelengths that you can
combine to try to figure out what the
most efficient combination actually is
so we did see that for red light has a
synergistic effect so again that is
nothing new but it is I thought was
worthwhile revisiting and it does
increase the quantum yield of
photosystem 2 it does make photosystem 2
more efficient presumably because it
helps to reoxidized a plasticy known
pool that photosystem 2 needs to donate
the
- and again wavelengths do not have
independent effects so how can we come
up with an action spectrum for
photosynthesis something to think about
so our future goals is to try to
commercialize some of this biofeedback
technology and I'm doing that in
collaboration with a local startup
company called fighter synthetics that
was actually a company that was started
by two graduate students that I had in a
photosynthesis class that I taught eight
or ten years ago we talked about some of
these ideas they talked to their advisor
about it he got a patent on the
technology without telling me about it
and the two students started two years
ago this company to try to get this
technology to market so I'm now working
with their fighters and Patricks pretty
closely - to do all of this so one of
the things that we want to do is to
build a low-cost chlorophyll formula
that is bond between fighters and
paddocks and an engineering professor
the instrument we use costs $15,000 we
hope we can build something for three or
four hundred dollars that would make
them a lot more appealing to potential
users so this is a picture of the
prototype of the flora model you can see
the saturating light pulse coming from a
laser right here shining onto that leaf
I hope that in the next week or two
they'll get me an updated version of
this floor model that may actually work
and apparently it's not easy to build a
chlorophyll Florida I would like to
thank who Veneto pharisee he was the
postdoc in my lab who built the very
first iteration of the biofeedback
system Jeff Weaver who I subsequently
hired to work on this project and who
will hopefully become my PhD student
soon did a lot of work on this shoe
young-sam as a PhD student in my lab
she'd had to work revisiting the Amazon
effect and my current postdoc working on
this Michael Martin the whole Lab crew I
would also like to thank Dixon de-spawn
yay for getting this topic on the radar
because again I don't think that I would
have been able to get the funding I got
if it hadn't been for his pie in the sky
while corn in the sky views so we may
really disagree with what he did but I
think he has done as a great favor in
many ways as well and these are the
various funding agencies that obviously
I would like to thank as well and
hopefully with that we have time left
for questions
would not
well so if you light your plants 24/7
you may have an increase in long
photochemical quenching over time and
you may be decreasing the quantum yield
of photosystem two so that may or may
not happen but I would love to see data
on that before I would make any heart
claims about that I'm not convinced that
you would necessarily maintain a stable
the electron transport rate if you keep
the plants in the light all the time and
some plants don't tolerate it like
tomatoes they need their rest at night
if you try growing lettuce on the
continuous slide I never have and
lettuce is fine with it no I mean it
would be easy enough to find out if you
have changes in quantum yield yeah so no
it is not a whole lot of light it is a
0.8 second pulse so if you were to
integrate that over a two-minute period
it's not a whole lot of light but it is
a whole lot of light that
that leaf has to deal with all at once
and that belief cannot do it's just it's
overwhelming the system
Oh
now pretty small yeah at most a few
percent but so it's it's not really the
average it out doesn't take into account
that all of this light is coming just in
a very very brief burst and that is more
than the leaf can can handle and doing
that over and over and over yes
no I don't think so because when we try
to maintain an electron transfer rate of
70 we saw a completely flat line the
quantum year the photosystem 2 was
completely stable so there was no
evidence they have any kind of circadian
rhythm while at a higher electron
transport rate we see that the quantum
yield starts dropping over time so it
doesn't seem to me like it's the
circadian rhythm that is involved yeah
yeah great question and plans definitely
adapt to different light levels and sure
young-sam has done work on that as well
so if you grow plants under higher light
levels they will actually be capable of
achieving much higher electron transport
rates they are making more reaction
centers to help use all of that live
energy and it's definitely acclimation
going on
well so you mean the LEDs on so the LEDs
are going on and off with a frequency of
1000 Hertz and you don't see it yeah but
there's no reason to do without a
different frequency but you can do it at
a very high frequency my understanding
is that it doesn't harm LEDs at all fast
I may be able to corroborate that but so
we're doing that already with a lot of
lighting that we are exposed to every
single day a lot of this lighting is
being controlled using the same pulse
width modulation there was auto hold
research where people were actually
looking at how does the frequency of the
light affect the photosynthetic rate and
there was a lot of really bad science
out there but it turns it looks like
there is no effect of frequency to speak
of and we've tested that as well that
was really boring data if we keep them
same integrated light level and change
the frequency the plant does exactly the
same thing
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu